you can't get more classic than a
centuries-old midday meal of bread
cheese and beer reinvented and marketed
by pubs as a plan one's lunch in the 60s
I'm now giving it my 21st century take
plumbers with the most amazing but super
simple beer baked bread hearty and full
of flavor
for a really quick and easy bread dough
sieve a mix of wholemeal and
self-raising white flour with a good
pinch of salt
salt is really important to breath it's
the first thing I do once I've cracked
it and smelt you want to smell that salt
baked throughout beer in about 250 ml of
beer
[Music]
the reason why this recipe works so well
is that the beer it's got that yeast so
naturally it's going to work beautifully
give that a really good mix I'm looking
for the mix to be quite wet because the
dough becomes too firm then it's going
to cook dry in the center
just as it starts to fall through the
Whisk that's perfect
beautiful this mix will work really well
as one large loaf but I want to make my
plan ones a little bit more special
small tins give it that kind of intimacy
and I quite like having my own little
loaf
the molds are really nice
lining with butter make sure you butter
the top
now a tablespoon of flour dust inside
the mold
that will stop your mixture sticking
tap out any excess
three quarters fill your little molds
and we're going to allow it to sort of
Rise just so it comes above the mold and
forms this really nice miniature loaf
onto the tray centimeter apart into the
oven 25 to 30 minutes at 180.
foreign something quite nice about the
smell of Home baked bread in the kitchen
delicious
no plan once it's complete without
pickled onions Red Onion is a lot
sweeter less harsh than a white onion
the early days of
plowmans you've got those ghastly sharp
pickled onions that make you almost cry
when you're crunching them on a lightly
pickle my red onion
just push your fingers through so you
get these nice sort of onion rings
little touch of salt a little sprinkle
the sugar and then a couple of cloves in
there that gives it a really nice sort
of perfume and sort of makes the
pickling slightly more mellow
red wine vinegar now Jim got red wine
vinegar white wine vinegar it's just as
good but red matches the Red Onion so it
goes hand in glove a couple of
tablespoons of vinegar
let's give that a really good
mix
to speed up the pickling process use a
weight to put pressure on the onions
as the weight presses down on the onions
the clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
work their magic and it comes up with a
really nice light fragrant pickle
for my 21st century plowmans I'm
creating an all-in-one salad and
bringing the traditional elements
together with a Punchy dressing
a tablespoon of English mustard a
tablespoon of honey
a touch of salt and pepper
and finish off with white wine vinegar
and olive oil
[Music]
now generally it's sort of three parts
oil to one part vinegar that's the sort
of General base
hmm you don't really think of a
vinaigrette with a plan ones but this is
a really nice sort of modern approach to
plant ones
for my plan one salad I'm using a
mixture of robust and crunchy romaine
lettuce
and Punchy Watercress if I was making a
Watercress soup I'd use the stalks but
the stalks a little bit better so I just
grabbed them like that pinch them and
then twist
[Music]
very peppery very hot but so juicy
Watercress in
your celery chop it nice and finely
it's the one thing that every leaves is
that stick of celery so scatter it
amongst the salad
a bit of oomph and color from some
sliced radishes and sweetness from a
thinly sliced Apple
whilst you're busy throwing your Plowman
salad together do not forget about your
beer bread
before it comes out I'm going to glaze
the top a little touch of milk that'll
put a really nice finish to the bread
back in for the last five minutes
now for the magic and the plowmans
generally you'd see it as a ham or
cheddar or Stilton Salmon's it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
so for the ultimate plowmans I'm adding
all three
for your cheddar
peel some nice shards of that delicious
creamy cheddar let's get them dancing on
top
your dressing drizzle around in circles
and then finally
are delicious lightly pickled onions
and the good squeeze
and not just dot the onions around
bread
is ready
it's got that nice yeasty smell warm
crusty and delicious
and there you go that is my classic
modern version of a traditional stunning
plowmans
wow
[Music]
my delicious all-in-one plan one salad
with individual beer bread loaves
updated for the 21st century
[Music]
a delicious saffron flatbread with
mussels it doesn't get any healthy than
that first job the super easy saffron
flatbread
put the saffron into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot water
that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the color
across your flatbeds to make the dough
simply add plain flour a pinch of salt
and pepper to a bowl and then pour in a
dash of olive oil
that makes the dough nice and silky and
Rich you'll saffron water you'll see how
concentrated it is now
and you'll need cold water
then simply need to bring the dough
together mop up all your flour
you can see now
saffron's activated it's got that really
nice color
beautiful use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
like this perfect beautiful
though
it smells delicious that saffron is a
powerful now sit that in your bowl cover
your cling film let it rest for 10 to 15
minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron I'm going to cut that into
three and then roll them nice and thinly
now lightly flour the surface
and then just
bring that
it's like a perfect ball
on the board
your rolling pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and just lightly
flour that on top
a little salt
cooking the flatbread is easy just pop
in a hot dry pan and they're ready in
minutes as it hits the pan it starts to
blister
is ready for turning
beautiful get that color on there
now you want it nice and crisp almost
blistering on both sides because it's
nice and thin it's cooked once browned
on both sides just cool on a rack
flatbread done now onto the muscles now
the secret
behind cooking
great mussels is in the speed you're
cooking
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start cooking
first thing pancetta I want it quite
chunky if you can't get pancetta I
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because I want to sort of render all
that flavor
add this tricky bacon
now Tomatoes garlic and chili
cherry tomatoes that's just going in
whole the garlic
just crush the garlic
it's all that flavor comes out chili
I want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked a little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
foreign
takes moments once it's brown and crisp
put your garlic chili and whole cherry
tomatoes into the pan
muscles go in
okay and I'm using dry sherry I think it
works better in this recipe than white
wine which is classically used at this
stage then oregano finely chopped stalks
and all I go on
and then just give that
a little mix
and see those muscles start to open lid
goes on
you've got to lock in that flavor gotta
lock in that heat the muscles will take
four to five minutes to steam in the
meantime cut your flatbreads into strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the mussels
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch I definitely don't
want to miss
healthy and delicious
it doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steam mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
[Music]
first of all cinnamon eggy bread with
quick stewed apples
I've never forgotten I think I was about
six years of age where Mum brought this
huge tray of eggy bread to the table and
it was like wow man we've died and gone
to heaven start off with a slightly
stale bread
four five day old loaf left over if it's
a fresh bread then it absorbs too much
of the egg so therefore it gets soggy
you never get it fried and Crisp And if
you're not going to use the breadcrumbs
eggy bread is a must
in France they call it pan Perdue the
Lost loaf
now thank you bread is great on its own
but serving it with stewed apples is
delicious so the secret here
keep the skins on it's a lot of flavor
in the skin and also it stops the Apple
from breaking down too quickly they get
these nice chunks as opposed to sort of
Apple puree
[Music]
now get your pan nice and hot and
sprinkle a couple of tablespoons of
sugar
take the sugar down to a light caramel
it's quite incredible how cheap it is to
make this and yet it was so filling
if you haven't got apples this recipe
will work pretty much with any fruit
you've got in
[Music]
to mix a pear and an apple a banana and
a pineapple just chew it lightly tossing
the caramel get a little knob of butter
that makes a nice toffee Apple flavor
really simple
now
you can see what's happening the apples
are caramelizing but they're staying
intact because the skins on the apple
and the caramel is turned into this nice
rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples a
couple of tablespoons of water in there
bring that to the ball and let that cook
out now the eggs
three whole eggs
what's got the eggs
add about four tablespoons of milk you
want the egg thick and Rich and then
lightly sprinkle in a couple tablespoons
of sugar
that sweetens up the mixture and when
you start frying the bread
it caramelizes it beautifully a teaspoon
of powdered cinnamon that gives the
bread that really nice spicy
deliciousness
apples are glazing Goose Fleet
and put them on a low heat and get a pan
on now for the bread
teaspoon of oil and stops the butter
from burning butter in
so that starts frothing get your bread
in it's going to be pretty quick now now
you don't leave the bread soaking
drain
and in the pan
once your egg bread has browned flip it
over
90 seconds each side that butter gives
that nice golden brown color of the egg
[Music]
beautiful
absolutely beautiful
it's quite remarkable isn't it a couple
of eggs splash of milk leftover apples
and all of a sudden you've got this
stunning breakfast
[Music]
now my apples they've all glazed
beautifully
get a nice spoon of that amazing juice
and drizzle that over
wow if my mum saw me doing this it
should kill me you're getting all Posh
again none of them I'm using a touch of
iced sugar to make it look stunning
that for me takes me back to when I was
six years of age
and I thought
I just won the lottery that is
incredible
thank you Brad
[Music]
you won't get more breakfast for your
buck my mum's incredibly delicious
cinnamon eggy bread with quick stewed
apples
[Music]